former UFC heavyweight champion Francis
and ganu is free to pursue boxing Mega
fights against the likes of Tyson Fury
despite recently joining MMA promotion
the professional fighters League the 36
year old had been in demand a free agent
after failing to agree a new contract
with UFC he signed with the pfl earlier
this month their co-founder Don Davis
has been speaking to Al Jazeera Sohail
Malik and confirmed that ganu is free to
box and explained how the cameroonians
move could be a game changer for mixed
martial arts
we listened to what Francis wanted and
we created a custom deal for him as a
fast-growing creative company the
professional fighters league is not one
size fits all we don't do things just
our way we listen to the fighters what
they want to achieve and create a deal
for them so if I can just get a
confirmation from you you're saying that
Francis despite his contract with pfl
will be able to pursue matches in boxing
not only can I confirm that he will do
that he's exclusive to pfl and MMA but
he is free to box and he will box in a
big way in 2023.
we think empowering the fighters is good
for the professional fighter sleep so as
they raise their profile that's good for
us so we like to bring Francis to the
Mideast in 2024 and we're here in Qatar
and we're also in other countries in the
beach talking about staging his first
Pay-Per-View fight back in two years in
the Mideast obviously the UFC a big big
name in the sport how confident are you
that you can rival the UFC as the number
one brand in mixed martial arts remember
MMA is growing 600 million fans but that
fan base is doubling every seven years
there's only 300 million fans seven
years ago there is room for more than
one leader in the sport so it's not US
versus them it's win-win-win and I keep
saying that over and over again what we
did last week was Fighters win because
they have another option not just UFC
and fans win because they have another
option not just UFC I wanted to do MMA
Jake Paul joined us a couple months ago
the global sensation and crossover so
when you look out to 2024 our first two
pay-per-view events Fran Francis and
Jake headlining those what more can an
MMA fan want